let me pull up the story from
timcast.com that should really grind
your gears New York City to house
migrants in four-star hotel where rooms
cost hundreds per night
how come I don't get a four-star hotel
what do you know my taxpayer dollars
paying for these these people this is
the crazy thing about what's been going
on that we've got this this massive
breach of the Southern border seems only
to be getting worse and then even when
these people come in and are shipped
around the country these cities are
propping them up putting them up and
giving them the gold star treatment
meanwhile you've got Americans suffering
under the opioid crisis you've got
unemployment skyrocketing inflation but
it's the non-citizens who are being
given all the Privileges and the
benefits this is why a lot of people
like you know aside from Texas people
are saying peaceful divorce or whatever
you want to call it yeah I mean you know
the the term that flies around a lot is
National divorce and you know the you
see all these maps of people with
different counties and you know the Reds
but but that's that's not how this works
right the the good news is we got about
75 or 80 years of kind of world history
to look at to see how this thing goes
down and in the the thing that I think
should motivate people is to understand
that this sort of divorce force that
we're talking about States withdrawing
from the Union
relieves a tremendous amount of the
pressure right I mean how many articles
have you seen recently where people are
saying there's another civil war coming
right has it already started but
understand that when you allow states to
stand up and be self-governing
independent nations they have the
ability to say like California governor
California let Texas govern Texas let
New York Governor New York and we can do
like every other self-governing
independent nation around the world we
can trade with one another we can travel
between one another we can agree to
defend one another when we have common
National Defense concerns we can do the
things that that honestly the founders
and framers probably envisioned for a
union of the states much better than
having to take a knee to two and a half
million unelected bureaucrats in
Washington DC Texas was also an
independent country for about 10 years
after five years I think was it five we
got we got a solid nine in nine years
nine years nine years they were they
were their own country
um and again what New York City is doing
is taking tax dollars probably also from
the federal government and putting
people in hotels right outside homeless
drug dense where the average citizen
there is of course affected by the
opioid epidemic that of course was
engineered by big Pharma and The
Regulators uh Tim I'm also seeing what
you're seeing I don't know if you want
to talk about it specifically uh what is
happening to uh Rumble yeah rumble's
crashing
um but I also wanted to let you know
that the guardian on YouTube is having a
live stream of Trump's announcement as
well the guardian on YouTube the
guardian on YouTube so I think also if
we play their stream if we get in
trouble and they don't it shows a lot of
hypocrisy that they're able to show the
live stream and we're not able to show
where where I'm on the Guardians
so hold on I'm gonna find out right now
um the the exact title and the exact
channel it's Guardian news it's the
Channel with 2.9 Million uh followers
and it's called expected to announce
yeah so that's live right now and look
at that that safeguards us a little bit
as Rumble is down we
the concern here is that Trump's going
to say things and YouTube's gonna
YouTube uh did this I think they did the
Crystal and Sagar uh over at breaking
points they've done it to rsbn they've
done it to Major I think even like ABC
got hit once
um you know I think maybe Fox because
you report on what Trump says they shut
you down and it's the craziest thing
well YouTube popped us we did so last
session we filed the Texas Independence
referendum act they did the committee
didn't give it a hearing which state
affairs didn't give it a hearing so we
did what was effectively a virtual
hearing we had uh we had voters submit
videos in the style of of testimony and
we ran it and the whole thing was like
24 hours worth of testimony and and we
streamed portions of it on YouTube as as
we did it and sure enough man we got
popped with a community strike or one of
those violations
um for for Testimony like literally
testimony of Voters and there was none
of that you know it wasn't people can
you know talking about
I will stress this though uh I will file
a lawsuit in 30 minutes if YouTube does
that to us because they have we have a
contractual agreement and this is where
Alex Berenson actually uh won with
Twitter there's a contractual agreement
that every user has with the platform
they use especially for a show like ours
that is a that is a financial contract
contract that we produce content revenue
is sold by YouTube the revenue is split
if they breach that contract by
suspending our access without us doing
anything wrong then I'm going to hold
them personally responsible for the Lost
revenue and then demand an immediate
reinstatement and uh and and at the very
least you know the strike lasts about a
week but I'll pursue it you know all the
way to the end to get that money back
the point is this no one here
is claiming there's fraud no one on this
show if Donald Trump makes some some
statement that violates their rules it
is not us as doing a show and offering
commentary they can play those games all
they want but uh uh you know also in two
seconds doesn't mean we'll win but go
get them tiger well that's what we saw
Alex Berenson got got suspended from
Twitter yeah and uh they successfully
sued saying that the Twitter made an
agreement that he would be given notice
of anything he did wrong and they didn't
they just removed him and they removed
him because the White House was
pressuring Twitter to do so so he got
reinstated there's also a very
compelling case showing hey the guardian
and the corporate media gets to do this
why can't we do this if it's really a
violation of their rules and regulations
why are they allowed to do it and we
aren't and this has been happening
throughout so many years on YouTube
specifically uh allowing the corporate
media to play by a different set of
rules while of course hurting people
that do exactly what they do showing the
same footage showing the same kind of
accounts making the same kind of
arguments showing the same debates but
if you don't have the connections with
of course the establishment with if
you're not the corporate media if you're
not the approved press you get punished
and dinged by it how can a judge see
something like that and say yeah this is
accurate this is totally okay for a
multinational corporation to do on the
world stage when it comes to a major
information Highway when it comes to the
public interest the public good it's
absolutely inexcusable with what YouTube
has been doing recently and it deserves
to be pushed back on I think it also is
important if someone on your show starts
spouting off and saying things that are
violate the sites terms of service that
you push back and explain that that's
violating terms of service and you can't
but is the guardian going to do that is
the guardian if Trump says something is
the guardian going to stop the stream
and say Trump was wrong are they going
to do that we will do that and it's
important that we do because people need
to know what the terms of service are
firstly and why things are happening the
way they're happening where do you have
where do you have reporting and where do
you have commentary
I don't know what this is all about what
is this video is not private the
guardian went made up they're watching
the show they're like oh they're on to
us it's no longer a secret yeah it's
gone Guardian guardian just shut down
the rumbles back up from what I'm seeing
but why did the guardian shut down their
stream maybe they were like oh we're
gonna get banned yeah I'll just I'll say
this like
what what YouTube has done with the
censorship rules has um created this
ridiculous media system that
if we host an interview with someone and
that individual says bad things we are
held responsible for it like so what
don't interview anybody ever again right
right how are you are we going to
challenge bad ideas how can we put
really bad ideas in check we can't and
and when you have so much censorship you
not only destroy the narrative but you
essentially try to of course have some
kind of psychotic mind control by not
even explaining the rules clearly the
the terms and services are very vague
they're very generalized and many times
people get punished and they're they're
not even told these vague generalized
rules and they have to self-censor
themselves which destroys the discourse
and destroys human progression human
progression is unparalleled with free
speech the more you deny Free Speech the
less humans prosper
and it's and it's ridiculous you know
speaking of challenging bad ideas I want
to talk about secession I'm just kidding
that was a joke by the way but that was
nice I do want to talk about it because
you're dead pan delivery through me did
you like it I'm actually very concerned
about it because it's what kicked off
the Civil War the first American Civil
War was a secession movement that'd be
great that it'll prevent one this time
well what what I'm concerned about is a
situation where Texas like we're out we
voted we're done and the federal
government's like nah that's our oil we
send it around the country that's our
golf that's our golf uh our Gulf of
Mexico access we want it and we need
that Mexican trade route so we're taking
it back you can't walk with our property
and then there's just comes to blows
other states are like hey federal
government you can't just go in on a
state like that they're Sovereign then
they join the secessionist movement
something like that again and how would
you avoid something like that well I
think I think what we're doing is is
trying to avoid that I mean that's why
we're following a process and this is
what I tell people you know the good
news is is that when we woke up today uh
it wasn't the 1800s right so post-civil
War the the world kept spinning things
started happening in the position on
this has evolved quite a bit right so
you look at what the federal government
has done literally since 1945 I'd say
you know post post World War II they've
sent our grandfathers grandmothers
fathers mothers some of the people
probably watching today our sons and
daughters like include my son uh off to
fight protect bleed some instances die
for the right of self-determination for
other people so you know what we're
talking about here in this process is
effectively the process that we have
seen the United States protect around
the world which is you put a question of
this importance to the people you let
them debate the issue and then you let
them vote on it and then you respect the
outcome of the vote now that being said
you know could the federal government be
at react poorly sure they could but you
know what does that say then ultimately
about the federal government right what
does it say because at the moment they
begin to start acting like bash or
al-assad or North Korea or you know any
of these other folks I mean they pretty
well just told us exactly why while
we're doing they've legitimized our
position in why the people of Texas
voted that way anyway do you think that
Abe Lincoln reacted poorly when he
started a war to stop the secession do I
think he reacted poorly yeah I believe
Abe Lincoln probably uh reacted poorly I
think that probably could have been him
but here's the thing I'm not here to
adjudicate the past right I'm not here
to to try to look back and second guess
what happened in the 1800s I'm here to
try to look forward to see what Texas
can do to prevent what's happening to it
right now thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time